your girlfriend's gonna leave you
your wife is gonna leave you
we're not falling for it
and the ones that left are not staying quiet
we're encouraging your girlfriends to leave
so you can leave me all the angry comments you want
actually I encourage it because then you're busy trolling me
well your wife is making a plan to leave and she's watching my other content
so come on give it to me
tell me look
I'm grey I got wrinkles and stuff
tell me tell me how ugly and horrible you think I am
because while you're distracted trolling me
your wife is making the plan to leave and I'm here for it
I'll help her in any way that I can
so come at me boys
come at me your wives are leaving you
your girlfriends are leaving you and there's nobody lined up
as far as we're concerned
the line is out the door
around the block
never ending so go ahead and keep treating them the way you're treating them
because they're leaving you in droves
and we're much better off without you